moving on now to more developments in
the west an ugly story coming out of las
vegas where a journalist was murdered
and an elected official that journalist
had been covering
is now in custody jeff gehrman who's a
longtime reporter for the las vegas
review journal was found stabbed to
death outside his own home saturday
morning
mark straussman has made his way to the
suspect's home that's where we find him
this morning mark good morning
good morning tony it is ugly and i got
to tell you in a city that is hard to
shock this killing is the talk of las
vegas clark county's public
administrator a man named robert tillis
will be in court later today to face
murder charges he allegedly killed the
investigative reporter whose stories
helped end his political career
robert tullis was wheeled out of his
home on a stretcher with self-inflicted
wounds on wednesday night his arrest on
suspicion of murder came days after the
stabbing death of investigative reporter
jeff gehrman and hours after las vegas
police executed a search warrant at the
elected official's home in connection
with the case we are exploring all
possibilities in this investigation
earlier police released footage of their
suspect and this vehicle a red gmc yukon
denali
telus was seen with a car matching that
description in his driveway
which authorities towed away wednesday
afternoon telus have been the subject of
a newspaper investigation spearheaded by
german in may describing allegations of
emotional stress bullying and favoritism
in the public administrator's office
that story included further allegations
that telus had an inappropriate
relationship with one of his staffers
purportedly seen in this video
he disputed the claims in an interview
with german accusing others of trying to
sabotage his office
i am about nothing but
justice fairness and just just being a
good person back in june as telus
appeared poised to lose his re-election
bid he appeared to go after german on
social media preemptively calling a
potential follow-up story a lying smear
piece and joking that gearman was going
through our trash to report it police
interviewed him wednesday afternoon
and he did not respond to reporters
questions as he returned home in a white
paper jumpsuit
later he didn't answer police as they
knocked on his door either
prompting a massive law enforcement
response that ended in his arrest
once telus was arrested the executive
editor of german's newspaper issued a
statement it reads in part we are
relieved robert ellis is in custody now
we can begin mourning and honoring a
great man
and a brave reporter
gail you're so right mark that was such
an ugly story thank you